Right now, you're trapped in games you
don't even know you're playing. That
friend who always gets better job
offers. They're not lucky. They see the
chessboard while you're playing
blindfolded.
Remember that group chat deciding where
to eat? 20 minutes of I don't care. You
pick. Classic Nash equilibrium.
Everyone's stuck in the worst outcome.
Here's the secret. Some moves work no
matter what anyone else does. Dominant
strategies. Life's actual cheat codes.
Like delivering more value than you
capture. Sounds soft. You literally
can't lose. They reciprocate. You win.
They don't. Everyone sees who's
valuable. The prisoners dilemma is
everywhere. Dating apps, climate change,
you're dirty dishes. But repeated games
flip everything. When tomorrow matters,
cooperation dominates. Most people react
while you're following the manual. See
the matrix.